but true to form the boys have given it
their unique twist using barley instead
of rice and is topped with cold yogurt
not parmesan
I mean traditional is the wrong word
can't call that a traditional risotto
they're cold and the hot sensation I
found it just chilled the whole dish now
for me is very sweet again yeah thank
you thank you no and that's it the
tasting menu there's certain dishes that
people won't like hopefully they're like
all of them and some more than others
but I said well next course is lamb yet
another dish cooked in a water bath
you want to spark a lot of spa baths
definitely welcome to came for a bath
I'm a huge fan of the sous-vide method
but the real skill is understanding
which dishes it suits correct me if I'm
wrong
that's where sous-vide cooking that
falls down because they're just very
much chew as opposed to you know a
cannon that wants that sort of nutty
buttery slightly gamey flavor yeah damn
what a shame finally it's time for
dessert an unusual take on a traditional
Italian pudding that starts with an
introduction from the boys our earliest
memory of good Italian cooking was the
dessert tiramisu given to us by our
father and takeaway Pelton's but you
know what the best bit here so sometimes
the best really is that simple
well let's see the way people make fancy
really see too much alcohol it's too
sweet you've got a site expresso that is
exceptionally good we've tasted some
outstanding cuisine but some dishes have
fallen short
technically I'm there in a league of
their own yeah
Stella really stellar and yeah you know
really the top of their tree but they
need to cook for the punter
yeah the moment they're cooking for
themselves they're cooking for their
parents and they're cooking for their
hero chefs it's always difficult with a
family restaurant but here more than
anywhere else
she had John ray and Peter need a strong
guiding hand and their parents aren't
providing it I don't think they give him
the feedback you can't as a parent he
cannot be that brutal meaning you can't
be a manager's slap it down and no one
likes this time to call the family
together for a debrief here's what we
saw highs and lows technically brilliant
without a shadow of doubt we need to
rein it in you need to rein it in and
understand it from a customer's point of
view not your ambition because when the
customers are happy you're happy you're
in business customers are the power
today and for me the secret behind any
good experience is how every else feels
in that dining room and there's a second
surprise tonight because there's someone
in that dining room that means a lot to
me because she organizes my life
Jennifer please darling and Michael how
was it very special and we've really
enjoyed our evening and we thought the
chef's or ingenious and talented and I
think at the end of tiramisu wonderful
turnout - really really lovely thank you
my undercover diners enjoyed their meal
but I'm still concerned over Susan and
Paco have they got it in them to run
this restaurant with a firm hand I love
my odds a bit some said that before
you know me and P there's no question
about it with ham viciousness hell we
want to be in the same vehicle autumn
Ramsey on Angela Hannah one day I like
to think we're almost there but this
makes me more than terms with a
politician or moment as an
overall-experience going out for dinner
yeah it was it was it was good but it
can be great I have just slow down and
rein it in a bit and they can control
their ambition and focus on their
customers they'll surprise themselves